the other news of the day as it relates
to quarterback contracts brady as
expected extended his contract
technically by four years but as a
practical matter by one year
teams are throwing more and more of
these dummy years onto the end of a
contract so they can push
cap dollars into those avoidable years
you eventually have to take the
reckoning
but as the cap goes up that reckoning
relatively speaking
is less than it is if the cap dollars
hit now they took his 25 million dollar
compensation package
dropped it to the minimum salary of
1.075 million
turned the balance into a signing bonus
that gets spread over five years they
create 19.14 million
in cap space tom brady doesn't take less
money
this year he still gets 25
he's under contract next year and what
amazed me if you flip
through your twitter feed today the
number of reporters
who were breathless in the idea that tom
brady signed a contract
that lasts until he's 45. when the guy
has been
saying for practically the last 45 years
he's going to play until he's 45. i i
understand
and and this is the sweet spot i try to
find because i i have
been very vocal publicly and as miles
knows privately
about reporters who turn up their noses
at stories because they're too lazy to
work on the stories
and they just say it's not a story it is
a story you're just too lazy to work on
it and you're going to wonder
what happened the day you get laid off
not you miles i mean you the lazy
reporters out there
the other side of it is don't take
something
and and make it into something bigger
than it is the idea that tom brady is
under contract with the buccaneers
through the age of 45 is meaningless
we've known
he's going to play until he's 45 it's
kind of like what we talked about
yesterday i think we talked about it the
gronk
announced or told somebody he's coming
back he said it in february's coming
back
so don't act like it's new it's not new
so anyway that bugged me
that's just it's like folks it's tom
brady we don't have to go out of our way
to make it
bigger than it is he said he's going to
play until he's 45 and now he's under
contract through the year in which he
turns 45.
okay let's see if he can win number
eight he's leaving 19
million on the table in cap space in an
effort to help his team get there and he
tweeted
let's go or whatever team band back
together let's go is what he always says
let's go get some avocado ice cream but
regardless
he can keep the band back together
because he's giving them 19 million
dollars they can use
to sign other guys you are on one today
man
yeah he is definitely giving them back
that money and everybody
is said basically that they want to run
it back except they haven't said run it
back because
as bruce arian says that was the chief's
bs so they just want to keep the band
back together and they're going for a
second one
and everybody seems to want to do that
except you know you've got other guys in
czech bear to say hey i want to chase
the bag right now
and i don't blame him for doing that so
if
shaq barrett's gonna be able to come
back and if they if the buccaneers are
going to be able to pay him what his
market value is or at least what he
believes his market value would be
then it's going to be because of
somebody like tom brady and the way that
they
have structured this thing and his
contract now so that they get that cap
space so that they can then go after
other players and
it's not necessarily just a guy like
barrett you know it could be other free
agents
that are out there it could be the same
sort of thing we were just talking about
with new england where
you get veterans who are either not
going to have the market that they might
have thought that they would have
otherwise who are going to be
unrestricted free agents or it could be
veterans
who are cut from other teams and then
they say well you know what hey i go
down there with tom brady
and i play in a state with no income tax
and i have a really really good shot
at winning a ring before i retire i
think that any number of players
would love to go down there because they
have now seen exactly what tom brady can
do
when he's in another environment other
than new england and they know exactly
how
well he fed into that culture and made
it a winner
so i think that a lot of guys are going
to be interested mike in going down to
tampa bay they get the chance
and even with the 19 million miles shaq
barrett may want so much that they look
at it and say well you're gonna find
another
shack bear like we did two years ago
when we signed him for a relatively
inexpensive amount after he left the
denver broncos
following four years in the nfl we can
get two or three
pass rushers load up the rotation and
see which guy
emerges as the top dog and then that's
the guy that we ride to another super
bowl appearance and
you know the state income tax thing is
an attraction it really is the lack of a
state income tax in florida
the the uh the lack of state income tax
though continues to be counter balanced
by the fact that they have things there
that will eat you if they get the chance
and i'm not talking about your cats if
you die at your house i'm talking about
alligators so
uh count me out florida i love you
florida but i'm not gonna live near
alligators
that's it hi i'm mike tarico and thanks
for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights from nbc
sports